♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, A LOT OF
PEOPLE PUSHED THE RUSSIAN
POLLUTION HOAX.
IF YOU PUSHED HARDER THAN FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW McCAIN.
THANKS IN PART, TO HIS EFFORTS,
MANY HAD THEIR LIVES DESTROYED
SOME ARE ACCUSED OF MAKING FALSE
STATEMENTS TO FEDERAL AGENTS.
HE FACES LIFE IN PRISON IN A
TRIAL THAT STARTS IN NOVEMBER,
FOR THAT CRIME.
BUT ACCORDING TO AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT, EVEN
AS HE WAS LEADING THE EFFORT TO
DESTROY THE LIVES OF OTHERS FOR
ALIGN, ANDY McCABE WAS HIMSELF
LYING.
WILL HE GET THE SAME TREATMENT
THAT HIS VICTIMS ARE GETTING
CUSTOMER FEDERAL PROSECUTORS ARE
WEIGHING THAT QUESTION RIGHT
NOW.
AND HOW ABOUT JIM COMEY?
A LOT GOING ON.
HE JOINS US NOW.
TOM, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
FIRST TO THE ANDREW McCAIN
QUESTION.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
YOU RAISED THESE OTHER ONES THAT
WERE TARGETED.
HE WAS REFERRED IN APRIL OF LAST
YEAR.
SO HE'S ALL READY GOTTEN SPECIAL
TREATMENT.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
AGONIZING.
THIS GUY LIED THREE OR FOUR
TIMES TO INVESTIGATORS.
WE JUST RECEIVED DOCUMENTS BOTH
UNDER OATH AND NOT UNDER OATH.
IF YOU TALK TO THE FBI AND YOU
LIED TO THEM, IT'S A CRIME.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
TO YOU OR ME OR YOUR AVERAGE
FOX NEWS BUREAU FOR DOING THE
SAME THING?
WOULD WE BE GETTING THE SAME
BENEFIT OF A DOUBT?
SEE FIVE HE WAS PROSECUTED
WITHIN MONTHS.
ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THEY ARE
WORRIED THAT THEY MIGHT GET A
DEMOCRATIC JURY AND THEY WON'T
GET THE PROSECUTION.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO SPEED UP
JUSTICE, NOT IN AN IMPROPER WAY,
BUT JUSTICE DELAYED HERE
SUGGESTS THAT THERE IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD.
THAT IF YOU ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
TRUMP WORLD, YOU GET TARGETED.
IF YOU ARE ANTI-TRUMP, YOU GET
PROTECTED.
STU THAT'S RIGHT.
LOWEST RUNS FOR YOU EVEN NOW.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE COMEY
REPORT?
>> Tom: HE ADMITTED TO LEAKING
DOCUMENTS.
THE IG REPORTEDLY HAS FOUND THAT
THAT WAS WRONG.
HE ALSO LACKED CANDOR IN TALKING
ABOUT IT WITH INVESTIGATORS.
NOW, SUPPOSEDLY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS REJECTED THE
REFERRAL FOR PROSECUTION.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S TRUE OR
NOT.
BUT I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, IF BOTH
ANDREW McKAY AND JAMES COLEMAN
LIE, IT IS CONFIRMATION THAT THE
DEEP STATE RULES.
>> Tucker: SO, IF YOU ARE 67
YEARS OLD AND FACING LIFE IN
PRISON BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN
ACCUSED OF LYING TO
INVESTIGATORS, NOT ABOUT
ANYTHING OF SUBSTANCE, BUT JUST
BECAUSE YOU LIED.
HOW CAN YOU LOOK OVER AT THESE
GUYS WHO LIED IN THE COURSE OF
ACTUALLY WRECKING THE COUNTRY
AND WATCH THEM GET AWAY AND
THINK THIS IS JUSTICE?
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> Tom: IT DOESN'T WORK.
IF I WAS THE PRESIDENT, I WOULD
BE PARDONING PEOPLE LIKE STONE
IN A HEARTBEAT.
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT
RELATIVELY MINOR CRIMES COMPARED
TO THIS COUP THAT TOOK PLACE.
I UNDERSTAND THERE IS A U.S.
ATTORNEY THAT'S LOOKING AT THIS.
BUT I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
INDICATIONS OF A SIGNIFICANT
CRIMINAL INQUIRY INTO THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CORRUPTION SCANDAL
IN AMERICAN HISTORY, THE SPINE
ON PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT WAS
ILLEGAL.
IS THE IG GOING TO COME OUT ON
THE PFIZER GAIT REPORT?
SAYING THAT THERE WAS SOMETHING
IMPROPER THERE AND NOTHING IS
GOING TO BE DONE AGAIN?
THIS IS A SIGN THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN TERRIBLY